what is the latest covert 19 data
telling us well let's look first of all
at the number of cases so the number of
cases we're seeing each day each of
these dots represents another day's
worth of data and i'll just put this red
line that's just showing your seven day
average so you can see the pattern going
up certainly and in that recent set of
numbers you can see 38 281 cases and
that line not quite as high as it was in
july for the uk as a whole but if you
drill down into different parts of the
uk well it's a slightly different story
so this shows you obviously northern
ireland very high levels in northern
ireland at the moment scotland wales and
england but look at scotland in
particular you might be able to just
about see that blue line there it's now
at the highest level on record so case
is very high in scotland and some people
are wondering whether that's down to the
fact that scottish schools have gone
back earlier than the rest of the uk
well if you break it down so break down
those case numbers by age group it's a
slightly more nuanced story so look
naught of 14 that's your kind of prime
school age group that's actually
relatively low in comparison with most
other age groups it's actually 15 to 19
year olds 20 to 24 year olds where
you've got very high levels of covert 19
suggesting maybe it's about
socialization rather than going back to
school but that bar the school age group
might well go up in the coming weeks as
schools go back and you'd expect that in
the rest of the uk as well so higher
cases but here's the thing we shouldn't
necessarily in this post-vaccination era
just focus on cases because the real
question is whether those transfer into
hospitalizations and to death and when
it looks at deaths this shows you just
deaths across the uk as a whole
certainly they are going high you can
see this line edging up and in the last
10 days eight of those days we've seen
deaths uh reported at over a hundred a
day so definitely getting higher but
here's the thing don't just look at that
on its own look at it in comparison with
cases so this black line shows you cases
it's on a different axis because
obviously cases are a lot higher but
what you can probably see is there's a
relationship between that black line
cases and the red line deaths in that
winter peak so that's the winter peak
last year
and then look now you've got cases going
up very high
indeed but death's very low around 100
deaths a day compared with when you're
at that kind of level we're at at the
moment back in the winter peak you're
talking about maybe 600 maybe 700 deaths
a day so that's encouraging that
divergence the question and the hope is
that it continues in the next few months
as well